pour le week end du super bowl il n'y a
pas que les ailes de poulet qui font
fureur
la bière coule également à flot le
marché de la bière qui génère 22
milliards de dollars au canada a bien
changé ces dernières années
depuis 2015 le nombre de brasseries a
bondi de 155% il y en a maintenant près
de 1000 au pays dont plus de 240 au
québec
les microbrasseries continuent de se
multiplier aidé par des mesures fiscales
dans certaines régions canada ya une
brasserie pour 15000 personnes qu'un
nouvel habitant juste un modèle
d'affaires qui est intéressant en soi
même si la demande a fait état de chutes
libres car malgré cette abondance de
choix les ventes de bière ont chuté de
4% l'an dernier la bière qui occupait
plus de la moitié du marché des produits
alcoolisés ne peut plus que 38% mettre
en marché de nouveaux produits devient
difficile ici à la microbrasserie cat
origines 50% des ventes se font sur
place
je pense ça devient de plus en plus
difficile mais il ya beaucoup de
demandes pour mme habyarimana
il espère tirer un parallèle ou à des
restaurants qui a eu beaucoup de
restaurants mais c'est les meilleurs qui
vont rester dans un marché saturé les
microbrasseurs compte sur les
changements d'habitudes des
consommateurs
c'est possible qu'on va voir plus de
fermeture de l'autre côté les
microbrasseries c'est juste 10% du
marché de la bière totale en ce moment
il ya une forte tendance pour des bières
limité donc les gens veulent découvrir
quelque chose en petit bac on assiste à
quelques acquisitions mais la
consolidation du marché restent modestes
pour ce qui les acquisitions il y en a
eu seulement que deux durant dernières
années parce que la plupart de ses
brasseries leur ont pas la capacité
d'augmenter leur part de marché en
raison des barrières et un provincial
qu'on connaît bien l'autre réalité c'est
que plusieurs il ya plusieurs
microbrasseries qui perd de l'argent
les plus petits jours sont encore
confiant d'arracher des parts de marché
aux grandes brasseries comme au sud mais
avec plus de brasseurs et moins de
buveurs certaines fermetures seront
inévitables
si michel marsolais radio canada
montréal